bienvenue et bienvenue dans parfum
numéro 7 pas vous savez cette émission
où on débat de l'actualité avec des
chroniqueurs récurrents quelqu'un qui
préfère les causes gagner aux causes
perdues je suppose
même si on dit parfois les avocats des
causes perdues mais n'est plus tôt
l'avocate des causes des décès florence
perk avec nous quand on est père ne pas
les perdre de façon trop fracassante
bonjour jean charles lajoie dit vous
mettez vous les écrivains à table voilà
tout et on va parler de justice est
justement l'une de vos dernières
parutions c'est le roman du l'ancien
procureur de la cour d'assises de paris
philippe bilger
à la 72 heures 72 heures quelqu'un qui
met les petits plats dans les grands et
parfois aussi les pieds dans l'eau à
temps à table à table c'est jean luc bat
bec et enfin une étudiante qui pourrait
nous en apprendre beaucoup sephora ne
m'a dit bonjour on peut jean-patrice
pour savoir ça va nous sortait juste
pratiquement d'un examen exactement
voilà mais ça s'est bien passé ça s'est
bien passé
1 ce n'est pas une maison de dire de
façon là on a une avocate
alors on va commencer peut-être par un
sujet qui a quand même attiré 8 millions
et demi de téléspectateurs samedi soir
la preuve que ça intéresse les gens
c'est l'élection de miss france et alors
moi j'étais frappé ben ça fait comme ça
quelques années je me souviens quand
j'étais quand j'étais plus jeune il y
avait des émissions qui disait mais miss
france est ringard c'est vraiment une
image de la femme qu'on veut plus voir
est aujourd'hui plus personne ne
conteste sa de votre ça formidable
peut-être que l'émission formidable
aussi mais elles sont très jolies en
tout cas mais c'est vrai qu'il ya plus
de contestations ça vous a pas frappé la
france
ben j'ai pas regardé l'émission
je crois que je n'ai jamais vu des
missions de miss france donc je n'en
pense pas honnêtement ça ça m'intéresse
pas vraiment je suis pas je pense que
c'est un business qui marche parce que 8
millions de spectateurs ça me surprend
toujours beaucoup donc mais ne les
trouvera 10 ans parce que j'ai vu le
lendemain
très élégante très classe mais vous
voilà je pense ça je ne suis pas
certaine c'est un choix simple non c'est
tout non c'est pas un débat politique et
voilà je pense que les gens ont alors
fait manifestement plaisir que de
regarder cette émission mais pas forcé
leur âge et je trouve qu'il ya un petit
peu un retour en arrière c'est à dire
qu'on retour un peu à une normalisation
d'imagés la femme glamour et et pour ça
je vous invite tous à regarder la photo
de la ministre de la culture sur le site
du ministère qui a une image très
glamour et je trouve que c'est un petit
peu décalé avec le rôle qu'elle a donc
part à miss france s'inscrit pleinement
dans cette dynamique de la télé réalité
de la sacralisation de l'apparence mais
toutefois quand même il faut noter une
avancée positive c'est que je trouve
qu'avant les miss france elle était
relativement potiche de nos jours on les
veut plus studieuse fantômes des études
actuellement la prestigieuse et dans une
émission c'est vrai qu'elle est non
seulement ravissante elle est
intelligente tant que normal débrouille
très bien dans les interviews à tout ça
mais on est loin de la télé réalité
quand même un attelage veut ce n'est pas
du tout accable et nabila mais enfin
quand même entre miss france et de la
wilaya quand même
je garde on n'est pas du tout on joue
pas dans la même cour c'est pas la même
catégorie c'est pas la même chose
après qu'elle soit glamour j'ai quand
même le minimum en fait c'est un peu ce
qu'on leur demande quand même à ces
filles là je veux dire c'est sinon si
vous voulez un peu moins glamour et plus
rustique il ya un concours de miss
agricole est lancée et les filles sont
très jolis aussi mais c'est vrai que les
les sur facebook alors c'est plus
particulier mais sinon voilà c'est comme
une émission sympathique qui fait de mal
à personne
effectivement on n'est pas forcé de la
regarder et puis les filles sont super
juste un peu étonné parce que on a
l'impression qu'elles font tout les
mêmes études et et beaucoup d'études de
commerce à lahoud ou de communication
mais après on voit jamais ses fils afin
de faire ce boulot là je ne vois jamais
bien quelqu'un qui dirigerait une boîte
m'a fait une école de commentaires je
suis une ancienne miss france tout
jamais ça plus jamais en fait c'est une
impression qu elles font des études
juste pour le pour pouvoir le bluff fois
qu'on le dit après dix images de ce
conseil oui bien sûr mais en plus
j'adorais geneviève de fontenay à cette
dame capable de faire le grand écart
entre son admiration pour et de les
griller et les paillettes de tf1 je
trouvais ce personnage temps réel et
très française finalement un donc elle
savait elle s'avère d'extrême gauche
tout en paraît sur tf1 moi je trouve ça
formidable
en faisant le jeu des deux bords je
regrette geneviève de fontenay pour les
miss oui je suis d'accord
elle a de plus en plus intelligentes de
notre joue enfin un débat en fin au
débat beaucoup aujourd'hui de la théorie
du genre
excusez-moi j'ai peut-être un peu avec
ça mais justement c'est l'impression qui
est une re sexualisation dans la société
c'est à dire que les femmes sont
maintenant beaucoup plus avec des talons
ou etc
les mecs alors il y en a qu'un parmi
nous mais ont de plus en plus la barbe
c'est à dire qu'ils se sentent plus
hommes les femmes plus femme
alors que tout le monde combat le
premier c'est que la de zemmour il avait
encore raison
donc c'est dur non je trouve que les
hommes font ressortir leur part féminine
de plus en plus ils ont pas la mitis et
puis ça devient désastreux
ils prennent des petits costumes bien
serré je serais venu ça veut pas dire se
féminiser la dent mais ils ont accès par
espèce l'espoir poussée des demis
caminati les yeux comme ça c'est un fait
à l'époque on n'accepte plus de mire
mais en quoi faire ressortir sa part
féminine est insultant mais
principalement sur tout c'est juste à
moi j'ai trouvé pour construire il y
avait alors que alors qu'en combat
il ya des gens qui combattent beaucoup
la théorie du genre disant oh là là faut
bien faire la différence entre les
hommes et les femmes
j'ai l'impression que ben justement une
plus grande différence qu'à un moment un
moment il n'y avait plus une seule gamme
et sexualisation et qu'elle doit me
s'est présenté vers un serveur tu sais
pas si tu as vu leurs médailles au
concours de l'eurovision c'est
exactement faire liberté quand même une
enfin rien d'un mètre au programme
féminin elle n'est regarder le film et
je sais pas si vous l'avez vu une
nouvelle amie avec romain duris qui est
formidable où il se transforme en femme
enfin le mans et c'est un filmeur voilà
c'est un coup de coeur
c'est une cote à oui c'est mieux quand
le car et si vous me l'avez vu à la
route de bombes et non les murs il a
navigué
je sais dire qui est un film qui sort
comme ça avec guillaume de tonquédec
guillaume deux ans et avec qui je fais
pas ci fais pas ça mais se déguise en
femme aussi ce sera aux associés aux
maggiori et ça c'est plus éloquemment un
ovni donc vous n'êtes pas d'accord avec
moi sur la sexualisation faire et
pourquoi on fait face mais mister france
galop un moment plus de femmes qui
portaient des talons aujourd'hui de plus
en plus aux femmes en porte en métal
s'est tellement je n en veux mais je
suis là je sais pas vous mais remarque
est peut-être plus alors on va passer à
d'autres sujets je vis mollet ce qui est
de sujets une identité qui me paraît
c'est intéressant il y à coignières un
référendum qui n'est pas un référendum
illégal sur l'élargissement de la
communauté de communes et les habitants
de coignières ont voté à 97% contre cet
élargissement
c'est de toute façon dire ben voilà on
veut rester chez nous on regarde un
sujet puis on en parle tout de suite
après 97 90 % pour dire oui au maintien
de la communauté de communes des étangs
dans son périmètre actuel comprenant
coignières maurepas les bréviaires les
essarts le roi et le perray-en-yvelines
une consultation populaire organisée
comme une vraie élection avec son
président de bureau son isoloir son urne
et ses assesseurs deux bureaux de vote
étaient ouverts dont la en mairie je
souhaitais que cette consultation ne
puisse pas être contestées et donc j'ai
réorganisé commandes organise n'importe
quel autre élection et aux municipales
par exemple c'est à dire les envois de 8
heures du matin à l'interné soir près de
36 % des électeurs quoi ni rien se sont
déplacés ce dimanche les habitants ne
veulent pas du projet du préfet de
région d'inclure leurs villages dans une
grande intercommunalité à huit cent
mille habitants incluant saint quentin
en yvelines versailles grand parc ou
encore le plateau de saclay huit cent
mille habitants de 100000 habitants on
n'a rien à y faire mais on a tout à
perdre d'ailleurs qu'en étant une petite
commune telle qu'on est on arrive mieux
à gérer que les grosses agglomérations à
chaque fois ça part dans tous les sens
j'ai déjà voté pour ne pas dans un conte
en yvelines et à des années les zones
est et je vois pas du tout pourquoi nous
commune coignières petit on y reste
maître avec un grand ensemble comme ça
nous laisse espérer ou penser quand nos
impôts moindre énormément si on rentrait
vous rembourser les 400 millions qui est
des deux communes de saint quentin en
yvelines
les résultats de cette consultation
populaire qui n'a aucune valeur légale
seront adressés au préfet des yvelines
au préfet de région ce dernier doit
rendre son arbitrage sur la super
intercommunalités à huit cent mille
habitants à la fin du mois de février
une superstructure qui ne convainc pas
au delà des frontières de coignières la
communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
et celle de versailles grand parc ont
également émis un avis défavorable à
l'or florence nouveau remarqué que dans
ce sujet des personnes
je suis mieux soit peu interloqué alors
est-ce que seules les personnes âgées
ont été mobilisés par le sujet ils sont
venus voter et carré 17 7% ou moins
faciles c'est sûr mais nos mains mais
c'est non mais effectivement il est
question c'est s'il n'y a que des
personnes âgées on peut comprendre
quelques craintes voilà qu'elles sont
pas très envie de changer donc oui il
interrogé s'il te vrai sujet puisque la
route dit il ya trop de communes en
france il faut vous en mai la
demi-journée je veux commune il faut se
regrouper mais bs que les jours la crise
de l'identité se ressent avec une
société qui est de plus en plus en plus
mondialisé et le besoin d'appartenance
on peut comprendre ça non mais non non
tout à fait on peut le comprendre
simplement là je crois que la difficulté
dans tout ce problème politique c'est
qu'il ya pas de visibilité parce qu'on
est en train de vous dire vous allez
vous avez une commune dans un
département avec une communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines en l'espèce
qui enveloppent cette commune et puis
après on va avoir des intercoms et puis
après on va voir ce monstre de huit cent
mille habitants
donc je pense que des gens soient un peu
perdus ils se disent c'est encore on est
quand même les spécialistes du
millefeuille est-ce qu'on va encore en
remettent une couche donc je pense
qu'avant tout est d'arriver à ccc
intercommunalités de huit cent mille
habitants pour peut-être déjà leur
expliquer que vous ai déjà expliqué ce
que c est pourquoi on se dirige vers une
intercommunalité à quoi ça va servir et
je sais pas si les gens qui sont allés
voter oui une information politique
économique sociale lorsque nombreux ou
pas voilà c'est sur l'ordi vous êtes
dans votre petit village avec la
boulangerie beaucoup à dire oui ça fait
et c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui on voit
bien
marine le pen surf allègrement sur c'est
sur ces thématiques la sueur du restons
chez nous voilà et c'est inquiétant mais
je peux comprendre que les gens sont
inquiets en dise on est bien dans notre
petit village on sait où on va on sait
où on est l'inconnu ils sont dans
l'inconnu c'est toujours inquiétant
c'est pas tant le reste on chez vous je
pense que les français en ont ras le bol
d'être emmerder et en fait on a toujours
l'impression qu'on vous emmerde ces
terres que les gens sont tranquilles
dans un village et maintenant on va leur
dire mettez c'était bien ça fonctionnait
c'est vrai mais on va tous vous changez
vous allez voir ça va être mieux on sait
d'expérience que ce n'est jamais mieux
très rarement en tout cas les des
réformes administratives qui sont quand
même bourré de d'emmerdements mais à
foison c'est à dire que le type qui a
été votée je comprends tout à fait à mon
avis il va voir un bureau de poste à 200
mètres de chez lui c'est très bien que
une fois que cette intercommunalité sera
beauté le bureau de poste on en fera un
plus gros il faudrait qu'ils prennent le
bus pour y aller entre-temps lure a
interdit heureusement ségolène royal a
lutté mais enfin on nous interdit de
faire du feu dans la cheminée
on n'arrête pas d'emmerder les français
tous les jours tous les jours tous les
jours et plus on leur demandera leur
avis plus ils seront là entre un terme
et non ça va on n'en veut pas arrêter de
tout changer de temps en temps on
pourrait juste respirer c'est
l'intercommunalité c'est peut-être très
intelligent mais c'est impossible des
matériaux vrille et réduire le
millefeuille et administratives et mais
il ya aussi d'autres doutent truc à mon
avis très important en france avant de
régler le problème du millefeuille
administratif à mon avis parce que va
laisser jean legrez pour d'autres c'est
fort c'est bas par rapport à ça j'ai pas
tout à fait la même lecture il faut
savoir que 97% des votants attendait
mais c'est un référendum qui n'a aucune
valeur mais n'y a que 3 7% de la
population envers cette communauté des
communes qui a voté donc il faudrait
savoir quelle est la tranche d'âge des
votants quels sont les gens qui se
sentent réduction partielle n'est pas
beaucoup plus de votants et exhaler pas
faire votre jospin qui n'aiment pas les
vieux qui fonctionne
view serait moins intéressant que les
boues mais non c'est pas ça
ce que je veux dire c'est suivant le
profil socio culturel du beau temps on
comprend d'autant plus s'il se prononce
contre s'il se prononce pour si les gens
qui se sont mobilisés ce jour là ne
représente que la tranche d'âge des
seniors oui on comprend que ce soit un
vote négatif
mais là où je suis pas d'accord avec
vous parce que ça rejoint exactement ce
que disait florence bonnes idées reçues
je suis pas persuadé je pense que pas
tous mais les seniors dans l'ensemble
ont plus peur de l'ouverture sur plus
réac que les nombres et ac ont plus peur
de l'ouverture parce qu'ils se sont
nettement en capacité de contrôler la
nouveauté le changement qu'on cherche à
le rapporter ses cages méfier des idées
reçues
j'ai beaucoup de respect pour le cpe qui
est un maire à ses formidables et qui a
fait de sa ville une ville
honnêtement en avance dans son temps
coignières ne l'oublié pas fut une des
plus grandes communes à vocation
commerciale en france à partir des
années 60 mais je vous attends juste
sous le cagnard c'est bien cette espèce
de truc horrible qu'ils veulent rester
là sam a vieilli dans la ville
hays parce que après coignières est
arrivé plaisir saint quentin en yvelines
évidemment sur montigny vélizy parler de
zidane mais coignard a été quand même
grâce d'ailleurs à la famille da sous
une grande commune à vocation
commerciale
bon alors ça veut dire quoi aussi c'est
à dire que les gens qui sont installés
avec leur commerce à coignières ne vote
pas à cogner ils habitent ailleurs elle
rit donc accueillir vous avez une
population qui est très attaché à son
village mais qui est en même temps une
population qui n'a aucun souci financier
à koné on paye plus d'impôt à coignières
on a des avantages importants grâce
d'ailleurs au maire monsieur cailleux
qui a su parfaitement bien géré ça va
bien sûr s'il faut aller au fond des
choses
et connaît il était naturellement il ya
déjà six ans mais sa voix y avait commis
un cadre très à l'aise dans lesquelles
les gens comme tu le dit mon cher jean
charles a juste ont peu envie est
emmerdé noms qui jouent là là on va
aller dans la ville nouvelle mais qu'est
ce que ça va nous faire de plus que ce
que nous avons déjà les habitants de
coignières sont assis sur un très
confortable magot ils ont pas envie
qu'on vienne leur bouffer parce qu'en
réalité ils ont compris que
l'appartenance futur à une
intercommunalité et éventuellement à
rejoindre ses amis allaient finalement
entamé leur magot à on peut comprendre
ce vote
maintenant comme le disait florence à
juste titre il faut plus d'informations
il faut également que nos amis français
capables de voter dans leurs droits
puissent exprimer les choses avec une
information plus grave que la fraude
alors bien fait ce qu'on ne leur donne
pas à l'échelle communale pas plus qu'à
l'échelle nationale je viens tous les
gens peuvent se renseigner par eux mêmes
les jeunes peut-être plus que les vieux
visiblement nous ne nous croient
beaucoup de capacités même que les
jeunes peuvent surfer sur internet
acheter un journal local et se renseigne
et éventuellement aller voter si ça les
intéresse donc là pourquoi est ce que
les jeunes ne votent pas c'est ça la
vraie question est de savoir pourquoi
les fusions dans le secteur on a dit
d'après les images vous voyez beaucoup
d'annoncés pas on ne s'est pas dit
comment était constitué le collège
électoral a je pense que les citoyens
qui votent ce sont simplement les gens
qui se sentent concernés par la question
posée je pense que les jeunes un
agrandissement ou non à une communauté
ça les importe peu on se sent
relativement peu concernés ceux qui se
sentent plus menacés
ce sont peut-être les seniors mais cet
accord c'est pour ça que le peu de
participation dans une élection - ne me
dérange jamais si des gens se déplacent
pas pour l'appeler quand s'en fout tant
pis pour eux mêmes ce sont des gens qui
viennent ce sera bien laisser dire ça
mais si j'ai beaucoup de respect et
d'affection et d'amitié pour toi viens
d'apprendre à dire ça là à 3 75 %
d'abstention à l'élection législative
pour remplacer c'est juste une
catastrophe
vous avez dit que oui mais à la raison
c'est révéler
pardon d'être un peu radicale mais c'est
pour ça que nous sommes là finalement
c'est par le dire mais je suis pour le
voc au beau gaillard à la barre ce ne
peut pas se plaindre d'avoir une passion
comme un qui marche qu par dessus tête
et en même temps parler voter juste
juste une petite précision
la belgique est le seul pays d'europe on
est obligé de voter est le seul pays au
monde à être resté 18 mois sans
gouvernement alors c'est comme ça marche
comme station belge est parfaitement
capable parce que l'administration
finalement a été modélisé dans un pays
extrêmement démocratique qui est un
exemple dans toute l'europe qu'elle
anime aussi intéressé sur le fait que
l'administration en belgique et
peut-être héritière de la notion du vote
populaire et par conséquent fait tourner
le pays sans avoir besoin de leaders
politiques c'est très intéressant on
peut pas faire un débat là dessus mais
ça a duré trois heures
mais je trouve ça très très intéressante
de no mercy aussi nous c'est
l'administration qui pour les politiques
il se pourrait qu'en belgique ce sont
les politiques qui pour l'administration
et c'est une autre vision c'est de la
société c'est aussi une monarchiste qui
veut dire que l'état continue je ne le
fais pas dire mon cher pétrin juste un
mot alors sur justement sur 7 sur ces
consultations dit au fond et voilà vous
êtes peut-être raison les gens veulent
pas être emmerdés mais est-ce que ça
pousse pas de problème de ces démocratie
locale de ces référendums locaux
initiatives populaires parfois comme
certains le veulent
est-ce qu'on peut interroger les gens
surtout et se retrouvent alors que quoi
et est ce que ça va pas dans ce cas la
rentrée des déblocages terrible sur les
réformes qui sont des essais en suisse
et ç'a bien fonctionné mais bon ok mais
alors en suisse séparés en suisse y
votent pour des choses qui vont avoir
lieu éventuellement dans cinq ans donc
c'est totalement déprimant donc
intellectuellement de quand on vote on
envie que les choses changent vite pas
dans cinq ans et puis cette jeunesse qui
n'a pas en france en mai c'est un peu se
tient rappelle que tout le monde nous
impose le tout n'a plus que ça c'est la
démocratie participative
c'est même pas ce que c'est que
démocratie qui serait pas participative
donc je vois pas bien le lait de la
différence et puis on peut pas demander
sans arrêt aux gens leur avis sinon on
n'avance pas on va reclasser ce que
c'est mais c'est passé sous sous sous le
sous prétexte de démocratie est ce qu'on
bloque pas les choses qui laissent leur
a tendance aussi par l'accélération des
informations de ce qui se passe à
travers la communication par le
numérique à être amené à changer d'avis
souvent c'est un vrai problème
là nous avons par exemple sur le plan
démocratique dans notre pays un
président élu pour cinq ans et une
assemblée de l'épisode également élu
pour cinq ans on s'aperçoit que très peu
de temps après que le président est été
élu et qu'il ait obtenu la majorité à
l'assemblée
bien sûr les français d amour il est
aujourd'hui je crois à 14 % voire même
en dessous de co2 peut arriver autant
est ce qu'il faut c'est de refaire
l'élection présidentielle certainement
pas mais en même temps en même temps je
pense que il faut que le peuple qui est
souverain
c'est lui qui dirige c'est lui qui
commande soient mieux formés mieux
informé et il ne l'est probablement pas
suffisamment dans le peuple est
parfaitement informé quelqu'un en france
qui se disent mal informés c'était un
candidat ça voilà c'est un ballonnet non
mais peut-être que les 1000 ma réalité
après auxerre s'est beaucoup les choses
non messieurs partir sur des actions
purement locales comme le 4 coignières
je ne sais pas quel est le degré
d'information que les gens à voir donc
mais cette responsabilité des maires de
donner une information qui soit neutre
et qu'ils soient pas orienté parce que
si le maire de bagnères il est contre il
a le droit d'être contre
mais c'est aussi dans son devoir de mère
d'informer les gens avec les pour les
contre
voilà le projet du préfet voilà les gens
qui sont pour dit ça les gens qui disent
qu'on va encore une fois chaque conseil
municipal est ouvert tout le monde peut
y aller tout le monde sait qu'on peut
aller au conseil municipal il ya
suffisamment de place des ports sont
obligatoirement ouverte il ya
obligatoirement une séance de questions
avant le début du conseil municipal
si on a envie de s'informer on peut y
aller et positif qui s'est passé des
mines personne car il vit pour et seul
un site très vite coignières sais pas où
est la mairie
réunion mais surtout que c'est un sujet
qui est important en cas d'évolution est
ce à ce sujet non c'était fait on va
voir un référendum
97 % des gens ce qu'ils sont contre ce
référendum n'a aucune valeur légale
donc le préfet peut faire ce qu'il veut
mais de tous pensons évidemment c'est
une c'est une façon de l'empêcher de
faire ce qu'il veut c'est assez pervers
quand même de toute façon il est quand
même une époque les choses sans parce
que le dernier grand référendum sur
l'europe ou la totalité des fins de la
majorité avait voté non nous et
finalement on a refait un autre
référendum pour qu'on voit depuis un an
pour faire de leur barda a été clair
faire un autre est pas là mais ça tu es
totalement inefficace nous que les
français avaient dit non mais je suis
content du résultat et je fais en tant
que l'on s'assoit bébé
mais pour en revenir au problème d
identité c'est un vrai problème dans
certains dans certaines communes et nous
participer lundi je crois voisins le
bretonneux
oui à une réunion c'est mardi soir d'un
des bars de mardi soir à
voisins-le-bretonneux à 20h30 et une
réunion sur le cluster du paris saclay
cluster c'est tout le pôle d'excellence
qui est sur le plateau de saclay avec
les grandes écoles les universités et le
développement de start up de chercheurs
de lien entre la recherche l'université
le monde de l'entreprise et essayer de
développer tout cela il ya une réunion
justement mardi la mère de
voisins-le-bretonneux nouvellement élus
organisent une réunion d'information
auprès des citoyens sûr c'est que c'est
que ce cluster départ ici quelles
conséquences ça peut avoir sur votre
claude parce qu'elle a des remontées
notamment qu'elle a eue pendant la
campagne municipale d'habitants de
voisins-le-bretonneux inquiet en se
disant mais le cluster paris saclay le
projet c'est 3000 logements des
logements sociaux des logements
d'étudiants et je crois que ça fait un
peu peur aux gens de voir
et des tas de nouvelles têtes sur le sur
le territoire le même problème c'est un
peu la même problématique que connaît
alors c'est autre chose parce que c'est
un autre ça oui au débat pas pour les
prisons qui est bien c'est qu'il ya une
démarche là d'une mère qui je vois là je
vois les choses assez à l'avancé
absolument je vais inviter il ya le
président de la fondation sur vergnet
qui va être la revoir robert cadalbert
comme un mémoire de saint quentin en
yvelines et du démarrage de ce plateau
de saleté et puis il va y avoir deux
personnalités qui représente des acides
et des associations de grandes
entreprises qui aident au développement
du cluster et moi sous ma casquette
aimez 9 78 c'est très intéressant par
les liens entre la recherche le savoir
il suffit de l'action le développement
parce qu'on fait l'idée la vie des gens
actuellement parce que c'est la plage et
sa banque à londres ce cluster a été
lancée sous sas par nicolas sarkozy en
il a voulu le lancer comme challenge
pour faire une pause ou cas d'en parler
je les cas d'une balle et quoi parce que
juste une précision
sa voix est ce que clijsters est un
acronyme un terme anglais ce que ce
qu'est ce que ça vous dit ça n'a pas
coûté un français si l'on peut dire pour
le dax et le pôle de compétitivité mis
sa peine comme ça wynn holmes en face à
la belgique
disons que pour éviter encore été
symbole d'excellence c'est ça le mieux
positionné kloster connaissez pas le
terme je ne sais pas quand les cibles
quatre jeunes non non rien qu'en vous
demande où vous habitez à faire vous
sortez d'où en fête de saint quentin de
chanter clause ans que je n'en pas votre
adresse et de saint quentin c'est vrai
alors je me souviens tout au cours de
mon parcours scolaire il y avait une
forte mobilisation la citoyenneté
européenne vrai sentons-nous européen et
c'est vrai qu'à l'époque je me sentais
pas spécialement européenne et c'est
vrai qu'à force de voyager d'aller en
europe juste à côté de chez nous petit à
petit prend la greffe et je me sens
davantage européenne mais oui très
sincèrement je me sens de la région est
ce que vous sentez chinoise ma foi c'est
peu il va falloir se sentir je pense
work on a appris en fin cette semaine
que la chine était devenue la première
puissance et économie mondiale
et puis il ya eu cette affaire de rachat
notamment de l'aéroport de blagnac a
toulouse quelque chose d'ouvert ou
notamment au dit que peut-être
d'ailleurs l'espoir investir et bientôt
à saint quentin en yvelines
alors on va faire comme les aime du
titre toujours faut-il avoir peur
faut-il avoir peur des chinois ont fait
on a peur de toi faut-il avoir peur des
photos feu des feux de cheminée je
trouve ça très bien qu'ils jouent le
vrai débat c'est pas les chinois les
chinois c'est ce qu'il fallait vendre
l'aéroport après une fois qu'on décide
de vendre l'aéroport qui une partie a en
tout cas il ne m est assez curieux c'est
que ça a l'air fort qui est rentable et
qui en plus dans une région qui est
quand même importante pour l'hérault
nautique française donc il ya quand même
un problème d'image mondiale qui est un
peu curieux et c'est vrai que c'est là
qu'on construit c'est vraiment affreux
airbus comme les hélicoptères ça c'est
quand même la capitale aéronautiques
européennes françaises et européennes et
donc de vendre ça c'est curieux
maintenant après une fois que la
décision est prise de vendre qu'on vende
ou chinois aux américains ou aux
moldaves faisait franchement ça n'a pas
d'importance
la seule chose c'est que les chinois ont
de l'argent au moins ils investiront
sûrement correctement pour en faire
quelque chose de bien voir ce qu'ils ont
fait au port du pirée s'était racheté le
port du pirée le port du pirée dans
d'expression donc c'est donc moi à titre
personnel je connais bien de la chine et
les chinois je n'ai pas peur des chinois
et je dors tranquille avec alain
peyrefitte qui a écrit quand les choses
allaient ouvrir le restaurant chinois
puisque vous abordez sujet majeur
il est clair que nous dans notre pays
sur 80 milles restaurants qui servent
leurs clients à table 60000 servent de
la cuisine ethnique et 20000 seulement
de la cuisine française
d'accord et il se trouve donc 60 milles
qui servent de la cuisine ethnique candy
technique ne voulait pas les italiens
par exemple si bien sûr avec tout ce qui
n'est pas versé dans les soixante mille
restera en servant leurs clients à table
qui sert de la cuisine ethnique une
grande partie sont des restaurants
orientaux
alors bon restaurant japonais belle
lurette ou à la peau neige et au gravier
damien thaïlandais et c'est ce même ça
c'est français
c'est réjouissant ils ont d'excellents
spécialité donc pour revenir à la chine
alain peyrefitte qui était un
visionnaire a écrit et quelque part dans
ce qu'il écrivait on aurait pu avoir
peur
cependant aujourd'hui la chine est en
train de devenir un des premiers
pourvoyeurs de clientèles touristiques
dans le monde
il y a dix ans il n'y avait pas un seul
touriste chinois aujourd'hui 150
millions d'entre eux c'est à dire pas
loin de 10% de la population se balade
sur la planète et j'aime autant vous
dire que les apports de cette clientèle
en devises dans notre pays sont
absolument essentiel maintenant qu'ils
aient acheté une part minoritaire parmi
nos jeunes en aucun cas étant entendu
que l'autre candidat aéroports de paris
a perdu la bataille à 50 millions
d'euros près mais pour autant l'aéroport
aéroports de paris société privée est
aujourd'hui manager sur un grand nombre
de grands aéroports internationaux
donc bon les chinois et ont pu vous
était plus fort dommage pour nous on
aurait dû probablement mettre un peu
plus au pot pour pouvoir garder l'année
près de toulouse ce pas voir les
échanges mondiaux sont là qu'est ce
qu'on va aller chercher à freiner sa
nous sommes en plein dans la
mondialisation
à nous de nous habituer à cela de ne pas
faire en permanence d'une espèce de
réserve et de fermer nos frontières
c'est bien idiot et ça irait aux dépens
de la population
est ce que justement le travail et
d'être politique ce serait pas de faire
en sorte que les les zones géographiques
puisse accueillir des investisseurs des
capitaux nouveaux qui sont créateurs
n'ont pas encore bien sûr à condition
que nos leaders politiques connaissent
mieux l'entreprise qui ne
le connaissent comme si nous étions dit
s'il ya un projet quel magnifique à
l'aéroport de châteauroux les méthodes
qu'on en parle parce que achetés par les
chinois l'airport cet organe et
aéroports et longtemps aux américains
voilà un des seuls endroits où on peut
vous poser dans la région à 741 problème
c'est des pistes qui est un projet
chinois s'ils s'opposaient à château
cela mais il ya un projet qu'un projet
chinois colossales et qui étaient très
avancées mais qui est beaucoup plus
important et qui va être créateur de
beaucoup d'emplois mais qui est une
sorte de tête de pont économique pour
toutes les marchandises qui arrivent de
chine éventuel quelques vues qui on
espère pourront repartir de france vers
le reste du monde mais voilà donc les
chinois sont là et en lui c'est vrai le
fait que au fond le pro l'un des
derniers pays communistes devienne la
plus grande puissance capitaliste
ben c'est une bonne chose pour eux alors
au détriment de certains il faut pas se
leurrer je crois qu'il ya vraiment de
grandes disparités en chine pour y avoir
été aussi plusieurs fois le riz chinois
est bien loin du quotidien du petit
paysan qui marche pieds nus dans sa
maison après oui où je suis assez
d'accord je pense qu'il faut pas avoir
peur de cette psychose autour du
libéralisme mais on est en train
vraiment de vendre un peu tout notre
patrimoine
tous les grands hôtels parisiens ont été
vendus alors aux saoudiens aux émirats
pas aux chinois le domaine de gevrey
chambertin a été vendu à un investisseur
de macao la tour eiffel alors je sais
pas si ça a été finalisée ce était en
pourparlers au printemps dernier en fait
je trouve c'est un petit peu dommage que
la france ne réussissent pas à mieux
s'il veut regarder sont notre patrimoine
licencie culturel passé pas très gênant
parce que je n'étais pas du tout au
courant de ce truc sur la tour eiffel b
c'est assez difficile de réflexes pour
ça je suis pas très inquiet vous une
sortie peut acheter à tout à fait deux
mois qu'ils ouverte au public et qui
reste la galère dans les reins ya eu
beaucoup d'investisseurs pendant les
vignobles choix
sap a donné des promos et intéressant
nous sommes le pays qui accueille ont le
plus de touristes mais au monde
bon on peut discuter sur les chiffres
c'est pas très important ce qui est
important c'est que nous sommes les
discussions politiques extrêmement
importante à l'échelle de la planète et
je pense que nous serions bien inspirés
de développer cette industrie qui est
aujourd'hui très très mal développé je
fais partie c'est un musée puisque
l'hôtellerie la restauration aussi les
bars les cafés etc il est tout sauf de
clients étrangers
écoutez sur le restaurant les templiers
à elancourt je dirais les 10 à 15%
essentiellement d'ailleurs grâce aux
entreprises internationales qui sont
autour de nous nous n'accueillons que
très peu de clientèle touristique mais
on sait par venant de l'intérieur on a
eu quelques russes chinois qui sont qui
vient sur les yvelines de plus en plus
les russes elle est hélas depuis quelque
temps on un ami un vrai grand coup de
frein à leur déplacement parce qu'en
fait tout ce qui est tourné autour de la
clientèle russe sur l'ensemble de
l'europe de l'ouest perdu entre 50 et
70% des clients issus de la russie
ces ressources d'ailleurs sur l'ensemble
des pays méditerranéens faisait que les
russes sont très gros client en grèce en
italie
bon ça reviendra faut pas se faire
d'illusions mais la clientèle chinoise
est en fort développement et au tour de
la chine également la clientèle qui
vient de
toute la péninsule médiatique se
développe aussi le japon après monde ce
que ça vous a pas échappé que le japon
traverse une crise nuit depuis quasiment
20 ans il ya un peu clients japonais
quand même qu'ils dépensent de l'argent
dont ils viennent chez nous mais elle
est elle elle est moins importante
qu'elle ne pourrait être mais la
clientèle chinoise est majeur 150
millions de jeunes chinois qui vont
prendre aux portes et 300 millions dans
les dix ans qui viennent
enfin si vous imaginez à l'échelle de la
planète c'est juste énorme c'est pour ça
que vous ouvrir le dimanche
alors jamais égalé j'avais fait des
ajustements salive d'hydro bcsa cette
affaire mais on y arrivait justement
voilà d'ouverture des magasins le
dimanche
alors il ya deux problèmes il ya lieu on
peut parler du principe s'il voulait
d'abord après peut-être de ce qui est
prévu dans la loi ce sera 7 dimanche
dimanche rennes doit encore un peu
compliqué me semble-t-il enfin moi sur
le principe même vous même un choix de
société on impose un choix de société
nous est ouvert 7 jours sur 7 comme la
plupart de nos confrères
sauf d'ailleurs et c'est tout à fait
intéressant de le constater nous dans la
restauration les états faisant très haut
de gamme à paris paris intra muros sont
fermées avant sa mise ou mais pour
d'autres raisons sur les biens sociaux
dire que ils ont besoin d'une type de
personnel très haut de gamme très fort
mais essai personnel tentait une autre
exigence et leur envie de beaucoup
travailler du lundi au vendredi mais ils
ont envie d'avoir leurs samedis
dimanches ce qui amène beaucoup
d'établissements très haut de gamme à
paris a fermé les samedi et dimanche
alors on peut s'interroger d'ailleurs de
la raison pour laquelle on n'arrive pas
à motiver des personnels de ce niveau
pour travailler le samedi dimanche
aussi étant entendu qu'ils vous êtes
très riche en provenance de chine de
russie d'amérique latine week-end à vous
n'avez aucun restaurant digne d'un pro
macarons michelin qui soient ouverts le
dimanche
bon alors c'est un long débat on
pourrait revenir
cependant ceux qui n'ont même pas même
pas
zéro j'exagère temps les taux dans les
restaurants trois macarons sont la
plupart du temps fermée samedi le
dimanche à quelques rares exceptions
je peux vous donner les noms et les
chiffres quand vous voulez cependant ce
qui me paraît moins intéressants qu'en
fait le choix de société voyez le niveau
en angleterre à résister très longtemps
à rester fermés
et puis les zones urbaines en commençant
par là on se dit ah non c'est pas
possible parce que la planète entière ou
bien chez nous on peut pas fermer sa
démence donc maintenant il ya la plupart
des magasins à londres mais aussi à
berlin mais aussi à rome mais aussi à
madrid barcelone sont ouverts samedi et
dimanche c'est comme ça alors est ce que
on se plie à ça on est déjà obligé parce
que de toute façon une grande partie des
magasins sont déjà ouverts le samedi et
le dimanche
elle répondit 5,7 certains 12 et puis
tous et bien posons nous la question
sociétale est ce que nous voulons
sauvegarder un esprit de famille
consistant à permettre aux gens de se
regrouper de se rassembler d'être
ensemble dimanche où est-ce qu'on fait
fit ça et je pense de la losc a dit
martine aubry
récemment la rigolote ce qu'elle db j'ai
quand même dans l'idée que les
manifestations family à mourir des
manifestations familiales dans supra où
elles sont quand même beaucoup plus
sympa quand les gens ont du boulot quand
il y en a pas je pense que le type il
est beaucoup plus content de louper son
dimanche que d'avoir du boulot est de
pouvoir nourrir ses enfants que se dira
c'est merveilleux ce dimanche de
chômeurs avec toute ma famille on n'a
pas cet argument chômeurs voilà c est ce
qu elles soient aujourd'hui c'est vrai
que non les l'idée qu'elle défend kippa
qui passeront soi qui est de se dire est
ce qu'on veut une société voilà où les
gens vous vont pousser leurs caddies lé
dimanche c'est vrai que c'est pas très
gai quoi me méfie ronde martine aubry
parce que martine aubry c'était la
première phase et c'est la fausse
inventeuse des 35 heures et lé
travailler 70 heures par semaine elles
sont vantés en disant hommage et j'ai
des journées de 18 heures alors donc
pour quelqu'un d'intelligent comme elle
18 heures par jour c'est bien mais pour
le peuple 35 heures c'est largement
suffisant par semaine donc là c'est
pareil dit bosser le dimanche il faut
pas elle elle passe son temps à faire
les marchés pour assurer sa c'est la
marche pas à chaque coup sa réélection
m'enfin bon
donc encore une fois ce mépris pour le
peuple de ses élites qui décide comme ça
ne vous ai pas besoin de travailler à
les voir vos familles le dimanche
puisqu'elle va qu'elle aille voir ce sa
famille si elle veut et qu'elle laisse
les gens allaient bosser et puis c'est
aussi un peu infantile disant que c'est
de faire croire que les gens sont pas
capables de même en tant qu'adulte de
dire bah non je dis non je vais pas
aller faire mes courses si j'ai pas
envie d'aller faire mes courses à fin
mai ils vont faire leurs courses la
semaine le samedi et un dimanche
il ya deux problèmes il ya en effet
souvent l'homme là il ya le monde j'aime
quand même des et là dessus des petits
commerçants quand même oui très graves
comme moi plein de villes de taille
moyenne qui ont aujourd'hui perdu et la
ferme au centre un pour aller vers les
périphéries dans des boutiques qui sont
incontestablement le choix de société
nous l'avons déjà fait qu'on pourra pas
revenir en arrière alors les belles
paroles de madame aubry je ne sais pas
quel électorat elle cherche à toucher ça
m'apporte pas beaucoup et d'ailleurs pas
de rouge la trouve celle ci jamais y
avait de l'humour dans ce qu'elle disait
j'ai pas j'ai pas pigé en même temps
s'est vu x to late on se dira alors
laissé trop tard en arrière voilà la
tendance lourde est déjà consommer on
est dedans et il faut aller plus loin
certes que effectivement si ça permet de
drainer des créations de richesses
faisant le grand dieu
maintenant si on veut revenir en arrière
et fermé les dimanches ok mais alors
pour tout le monde et toute l'année
mais attention on va être tout seul tu
avais tu devras mois ne serait ce qu'en
tant qu'étudiante je suis pour que le
dit mon dieu on puisse travailler oui
l'ouverture parce qu'effectivement il
faut travailler on a besoin d'argent à
les temps sont durs en étudiant de plus
en plus tard c'est payé double et ça
représente une réelle opportunité pour
nous d'ailleurs il ya beaucoup
d'étudiants qui se dirige vers castorama
leroy merlin parce que c'est ouvert et
je rejoins pleinement jean-charles je
pense que comme il dit passé un temps
ensemble lorsqu'on a la disponibilité
d'esprit parce qu'on a de l'argent qui
rentre pour rassurer les factures chaque
mois on peut effectivement passer un bon
moment ensemble mais si on est déprimé
avoir du temps libre
c'est rare
et puis justement les gens qui ont un
pouvoir d'achat suffisant qui ont envie
de regarder un bon film en famille ou
aller au musée
rien ne les en empêche donc justement il
faut laisser la possibilité aux autres
de pouvoir opter pour ça avec avec
peut-être enfin en tout cas est ce que
c'est normal aussi que les salariés qui
travaillent le dimanche faut protéger
soit mieux protéger les autres que qu'on
négocie des hausses de salaires il faut
des compensations ça me paraît normal ou
et non en l'état actuel de ce que nous
sommes de la société telle qu'elle est
construite c'est normal que les gens qui
font l'effort de travailler le dimanche
soit mieux rémunéré et protégé et même
un jour de récupération sescas pas
d'ailleurs la plupart du temps dans tous
les cas sauf d'ailleurs dans la
restauration ou de mm mais parce que
nous sommes vous méritez a débuté il ya
longtemps et puis il faut donc le quai
qui font que mais est-ce que la ronde
est pas encore on parlait tout à l'heure
pour coignières de tête de blocage pour
les réformes
est-ce que là on est en train de
débattre et pourquoi cette douce
dimanche enfin je sais pas pour deux
dimanches maximum quoi halal alors dans
la loi c'est indiqué qu'on passerait à
12 mais enfin ils ont mis 12 pour
pouvoir négocier en dessous non classés
ça en fait plus penser que ça va se
finir à 7 ans à peu près bien sûr ces
deux marines et de centres commerciaux
où ses 52
l'embarcation voilà locales et
s'investit oui c'est un débat de société
mais c'est peut-être non plus pas mal
aussi de laisser au pouvoir le coup la
possibilité dire la wii a besoin il n'y
a pas besoin donc d'autant qu'à la
boucle est bouclée pourrait faire des
petits référendum comme haut débit de
ses biens toujours sur ce problème entre
la réforme le blocage de ces derniers je
suis honnête je pense que tu as raison
au niveau de la du pouvoir des maires
parce que je lisais un article
il ya peut-être une dizaine de jours sur
marseille ou dicks en fait ça n'a pas
marché parce qu'il y avait des rues qui
étaient commerçants depuis après 3,4 upa
commerçants puis après une commerçante y
avait pas de l'unité et du coup ça là sa
démission a pas prise et ça marche ça
pas très bien fonctionné
donc si au moins au lieu de paris une
fois plus on dit c'était le type de zone
tous types de zones non ce serait mieux
que localement il ya une harmonie afin
dé poils qui se trouve mais pas
suffisamment abordé notamment dont la
présentation de la lourde accroc puisque
c'est de ça dont il s'agit c'est le
petit commerce c'est vrai que le petit
commerce de son corps il ya vraiment
besoin de se développer devraient être
ouverts aussi en centre-ville et je
dirais particulièrement centre ville le
samedi et le dimanche sauf que ça oblige
évidemment à recruter et aujourd'hui
vous avez des critiques arrivent à se
mettre au vert si c'est son propriétaire
qui est voilà mais bien sûr donc il faut
pouvoir recruter parce que c'est très
tellement difficile moi ce que j'appelle
le petit commerce et c'est ce qu'on
appelle le globalement et depuis tout
temps l'arabe du coin ayant nommé y en a
plein paris il y en avait il ya des
meilleurs gardiens du sénat mais y'en à
versailles ils bossent comme des malades
et sont ouverts toute la journée jusqu'à
2 heures du matin
ouvert tous les samedis tous les
dimanches ce qu'ils sont des charges que
désormais je veux dire de ce petit
commercial à il est extraordinaire et
merveilleux et la cdm équipe enfin c'est
les gens qui postent tout à coup sûr que
quand on va dans les petits de province
qui sont quelque part notre culture nous
tous on est tous issus de là on se rend
compte que les centres villes sont
fermés
désespérément morts et si jamais ça
devait ouvert comme le sont les magasins
de périphérie
ça nécessiterait quand même pendant une
facilitation des recrutements des chats
on va pas revenir sur le sujet mais il
me paraît essentiel que le politique
quelle que soit sa couleur s'occupe un
peu de ces sujets là il y as
probablement des centaines de milliers
d'emplois à créer dans ce domaine est
justement fait un bémol que j'aimerais
apporter par rapport à cette loi c'est
que l'objectif c'est pour les touristes
les fameux touristes étrangers sur les
champs de pouvoir dépenser linux mais
également créer une l'emploi je pense
que le souci avec cette loi si justement
en élargissant juste le nombre de
dimanches ça n'est pas ce soit contre sa
fureur d'emplois on va demander aux
salariés des entreprises de participer
moi je sais pas ce que j'ai été vendeuse
donc ça se passait comme ça dans mon
enseigne ont du bon on va vous
choisissez un ou deux dimanches
et puis vous êtes obligés de travailler
alors obligé pas obligé de toute façon
c'est comme ça et je pense qu'il
faudrait dans cette loi pour que ce soit
efficace et créateurs d'emplois créés
des quotas spécifiques
c'est à dire il ya tant de quotas qui
peuvent être allouées à nos salariés est
temps de quotas pour lesquels
obligatoirement on doit recruter du
personnel
ça crée de la précarité limité pour
faire plaisir à tout le monde
comme toujours debout productique tout
genre le home à chromé qui vous concerne
directement
florence était hier enfin jeudi
manifestation des avocats ce mercredi
pardon mercredi un avis à manifestation
des avocats des notaires huissiers décès
ou sa fraîcheur rappelé concernant les
avocats les trois raisons c'est à dire
l'ouverture de capital du capital à des
investisseurs qui ne sont pas des
avocats la disparation de la postulation
sera plus obligé de faire appel à un
avocat dès lors dans l'ordre locales
pour défendre et puis la création de
l'avocat salariés en entreprise sont les
trois les trois facteurs qui vous qui
est en train de votre votre grogne là
quand même on a vraiment l'impression
que c'est une défense un peu catégorie
elle non bah oui enfin ça c'était
clairement les les personnes qui étaient
dans la rue hier on était cinquante
mille 50 mille les chiffres varient
entre 30000 et 50 mm donc ce qui est
déjà jaguar effectivement on a dû les
laisser en périphérie à prendre le métro
parce que c'était un peu bouché donc oui
il y avait donc un avocat notaire
commissaire priseur et huit cette
justice alors on n'a pas tout à fait le
même combat sur sur la loi macron parce
que nous n'avons pas de problème de
numerus clausus et de terre ce sont les
notaires les notaires eux la loi made
you turn s'avère que aujourd'hui que des
diplômes voilà aujourd'hui un jeune qui
sort après avoir fait cinq ans d'études
voit jeter de nous racheter il doit
acheter une charge et s'endetter il peut
par s'installer comme notaire donc la
loi macron a prévu justement d'abattre
bienvenue maintenant ce que je trouve
médaillon cerner non mais je pense que
c'est normal qu'on puisse s'installer
librement nous on s'installe librement
donc simplement la seule chose que noté
le conseil d'état parce que le conseil
d'état a rendu son avis mardi la veille
la veille il expliquait qu'il ya quand
même une rupture d'égalité parce que les
gens qui se sont saignés aux quatre
veines pour acheter une charge et qui se
retrouve maintenant avec des notaires
commercial et c'est un buzz un peu le
même sujet si simple et c'est un peu le
même sujet lorsqu'on a supprimé la
professions des avoués de près de la
cour d'appel qui ont été indemnisées
ils ont été indemnisées sauf que là sur
les notaires il n'est pas prévu d'être
et donc ils auront toujours leur rendre
leurs emprunts à rembourser
voilà donc ça c'est pour les voilà donc
il faut trouver nani fort et il faut
trouver un terrain d'entente mais en
fait que ce soit pour vous les avocats
les notaires 18 siècle c'est enfin la
grosse problématique de la loi macro
c'est que là on a bien vu que c'est une
loi fourre tout le dimanche les avocats
les trier par or il ya de tout voilà ça
c'est un reproche
il ya ça ensuite le deuxième point c'est
que on n'a pas été consultée enfin
gilles n'y a pas eu de consultation
c'est une loi qui a été prise à la
hussarde et surtout et ça le conseil
d'état l'a relevé
c'est qu'il ya eu aucune étude d'impact
normalement quand on prend un projet de
loi on doit obligatoirement faire une
étude
donc on prend les grandes décisions à la
hussarde sans étudier l'impact que ça va
avoir et si je fais court sur cette
toile mâcon par rapport aux avocats et
c'est surtout une appréhension plus des
avocats de province que des avocats à
paris et région parisienne
c'est une espèce de 2 comment dire de
disparition de désertification du milieu
judiciaire dans la province avec les
petits cabinets d'avocats qui se
trouvaient dans des vignes peu
importantes avec des tribunaux de grande
instance devant lesquels ils pouvaient
postuler et représenter des justiciables
dès lors qui aura plus de postulation
ces cabines et là vous mourir et vont
faire mais j'ai surtout dit l'avocate
quand même ce matin sur une radio
nationale qui dit bafa la postulation
c'est quand même notre merde désolé les
justiciables vous êtes obligés à prendre
un avantage car alors que vous avez un
jardin ça mais je suis tout à fait
d'accord
in fine et scénique pour le justiciable
ça parce que dit on pas pour les
justiciables mais la raison mais les
faits ça veut dire que tous ces cabinets
la cij et jusqu'au bout ou vont fermer
boutiques parce qu'ils auront plus
d'affaires et ils pourront plus voilà
représenter si l'on donne un crime parce
qu'ils sont obligés parce qu'on est
obligé mais parce que la science mais
parce que ebay non mais parce que vous
avez des endroits en france où c'est
quand même un peu le désert où il n'y a
pas d'affaires il n'y a pas d'affaires
où il ya un vrai problème c'est la
regretter un manque de criminalité non
c'est non je ne parle pas des et puis ça
veut dire que si j'avais été si vous
aimez plus ces petits cabinets ces dames
qui va faire les permanences qui va
faire des gardes à vue qui va apprendre
les aides juridictionnelles qui va
prendre les commissions d'office pour
les gens du coin s'il y a plus ces
cabinets là puisqu'il faut va falloir
couple et tout cela avec l'ouverture du
capital ne se dire ça y est vous allez
avoir des très gros au cabinet qui vont
s'installer au niveau des cours d'appel
et sur des petits cabinets qui déjà ont
du mal aujourd'hui à s'en sortir et ils
s'en sortiront plus du tout et les gens
quand ils font le marché qui vont voir
l'avocat parce qu en province un peu ça
dans les petits des petites villes les
petits villages ça se passe de cette
manière là ils vont à la fin du marché
et voir l'avocat
ils auront plus d'avocat lors la nature
a horreur du vide vous aurez des
associations locales avec des gens qu'on
pas fait de droit qui viendront
à dispenser de la bonne ou mauvaise
parole et je pense que ça va dégrader
considérablement le droit ça va pas être
bon pour les justiciables et c'est de
dire là le droit c'est pas une boîte de
petits pois ça se traite pas de la même
manière et c'est ce que je regrette que
tout ça soit piloté du ministère des
finances à bercy ça ne soit pas le
ministère normes et auxiliaires de
justice où les on est auxiliaire de
justice ont dépendu bâle a clairement
c'est une loi économique donc en fait on
susurre s'est alors portée peut-être le
fond des choses mais sur ces blocages là
aussi mais il faut qu'on se modernisant
je montrais javaux quatre danses que
moderniser les deux peut-être d'autres
chaque fois que bon bien sûr est
concerné on voit qu'ils sont c'est quand
même un pays très difficile à gouverner
absolument mais qu'il ya aussi
visiblement c'est que les pharmaciens
les avocats les notaires va taper sur
les pharmaciens aujourd'hui temps vous
plaît voilà c'est à dire la vérité voilà
ce sont quand même des corporations et
des groupes qui traditionnellement sont
pas les électeurs de base de la gauche
et de la gauche
donc c'est aussi pour ça que montebourg
avait balancé ça et que je sais c'est
tellement pratique pour un pouvoir de
deux éventuels et la droite veut dire
aller la gauche 10 avril c'est une
réforme de droite donc ma page de dire
si ces mesures sur un peu étonné quand
des gens de gauche se disent on fait des
trucs de droite ou quand des gens de
droite disent on fait le truc de gauche
ce qui laisse les gens et l'opinion
estimer si cette droite où cette gauche
si c'est bien c'est pas bien et puis
voilà mai mais en face c'est quand même
c'est vrai qu'il ya peu d'avocats et de
médecins et enfin les deux une formation
qui hypothèque vous avez confiance dans
la justice de ce pays
pas du tout moi totalement la toux la
justice merveille alors non d'abord
c'est évidemment beaucoup trop long
quand on est au barreau de versailles de
paris où d'aix-en-provence ça prend des
années sur honnêtement des positions des
magistrats qui sont souvent très
étonnante
donc non mon jeu très très sincèrement
j'ai du mal à avoir une date indique
avions offert notre justice est sous le
bras j'ai vraiment du mal
et je crains que il y ait un gros
travail à faire pour remettre tout ça
d'aplomb travail que beaucoup ont essayé
de faire mais n'ont pas réussi à faire
mais c'est dangereux on voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui
l'opinion est très en retrait par
rapport à la justice de leur pays et ça
c'est grave dangereux en plus c'est
préjudiciable à l'avenir
non mais peut-être trouvé une certaine
lenteur mais mettent déjà la lenteur
mais la lenteur et préjudice à la gauche
n'ose lever tout le monde n'a pas envie
d'être malade on n'a pas envie d'aller
devant un juge
le problème de la justice c'est un
problème de moyens on a fait partie des
pays où on a le plus faible dans le
budget c'est un choix politique de
cession du budget c'est un choix
politique de derrière on donne 1 % au
budget de la justice pour 72 heures
puisque c'est une set ce qui se passe
dans une cour d'assises qui gère donc
qui était le procureur de la cour
d'assises de paris pour paris pendant 20
ans et qui a écrit cette histoire où il
se fait effectivement lui ancien avocat
général à la place d'un accusé et qui
raconte pour ça que ça s'appelle 72
heures keira jours trois jours de procès
d'assises
et donc c'est vraiment ça fait un peu
qu'on a ce match mais je vais pas vous
donner la fin parce qu'il ya un peu de
suspense etc mais
moi ça me rassure quand même parce que
ça fonctionne et les portraits sont un
peu à charge un peu un renoir et on peut
on peut reconnaître pour connecter juge
d'instruction tel grand avocat telle tel
journaliste juridique et enfin
judiciaire pardon mais même moi je reste
quand même et il a en plus je dois dire
que je vois très souvent philippe bilger
parce qu'on est en plein de lancement de
ce livre je connais aussi beaucoup
d'avocats je trouve que ce sont des
professions voilà qui sont tous
passionnés par leur boulot et je pensais
que moi je fais entièrement confiance à
la justice on peut effectivement la
trouvais lente mais je trouve que j'ai
découvert vraiment puisque les vrais
cons en tout cas moi je n'avais pas
d'amis avocat général jusqu'à présent
donc j'ai découvert ce boulot de
magistrat était quand même bien
particulier joue beaucoup d'amis avocat
je connaissais bien
en revanche le blues avocat je trouve
que tous ces gens font un travail
remarquable
alors après avec l'effectif parisien
images de moyens inquiéter ramé paris je
pense que la france ne rogne les prisons
françaises ne regorge pas de d'innocents
que les demandes déjà non mais oui il
regorge de monde mais oui mais ça c'est
ça c'est ça mon goût mais il faudrait
faire plus de prison c'est tout mais en
france par rapport à ce problème de
détenus on est le pays où on prononce
n'est pas donné plus longue longue
longue et c'est l'heure c'est aussi le
paysage où il ya le moins de prison par
rapport à la population de places de
prison en à louis monospace de prison à
la haye en allemagne en appelant ses
membres étaient présents j'aimerais
sephora vous aviez préparé un coup de
coeur
oui tout à fait je voudrais alors c'est
un livre qui s'appelle article d'accord
donc qui s'appelle art ips et se livrer
les sorties suite à un an de création
d'une newsletter qui arrive sur vos
boîtes mails donc aux abonnés c'est
gratuit et tous les jours ou trois fois
par semaine en tout cas minimum vous
recevez une anecdotes originales sur une
d'art donc ça permet de rafraîchir sa
culture en terme d'offre d'achat va de
l'antique au contemporain y en a pour
tous les goûts
ça prend à peu près une minute vous avez
des liens qui vous redirige vers
l'artiste et si vous voulez en savoir
plus sur ces différentes heures donc je
vous invite à vous abonner à la
newsletter et à acheter l'oeuvre et de
la même façon mon dernier coup de coeur
aux newsletters c'était au sujet du
tableau de courbet l'atelier du peintre
donc il y avait toute une anecdote je
vous laisse découvrir sur le site mais
en tout cas il faut savoir que ce
tableau au musée d'orsay fait l'oeuvre
d'une restauration avec toujours ce
principe de participation citoyenne et
vous pouvez participer finançant la
présentation via un appel aux dons pour
la restauration de ce tableau et puis
vous avez différentes contreparties qui
sont toutes très intéressantes et votre
nom figure aussi bien sur le site
internet ne pourrait pas par des épées à
la restauration de l'origine du monde
public
merci beaucoup pour ce pour ce coup de
coeur merci à tous les quatre voies
l'édition est terminé on se fasse
retrouver la semaine prochaine pour une
dernière émission de l'année je propose
qu'on fasse à la fois un petit bilan et
puis peut-être vos souhaits pour l'année
prochaine à nos souhaits à vos souhaits
alors merci à tous au revoir
bonne journée
je porte au stick il a été